>> I had the opportunity to get to know Chef
Cardoz two years ago when I was a [INDISTINCT]
in his restaurant, a very ineffective one,
peeling garlic, but to say we're all in for
a super, amazing treat today would be a serious
understatement. Raised in both Bombay and
Goa, Chef Cardoz attended culinary school
in Bombay, spending time in the kitchens of
the Taj Hotel and also Les Roches in Switzerland.
He eventually moved to New York where he worked
with his mentor, Gray Kunz, at New York's
Lespinasse, rising from chef de partie to
executive sous-chef over the five years that
he was there. Floyd went on to open Tabla
with Danny Meyer in 1998. And as executive
chef of Tabla, he introduced diners to his
groundbreaking, new Indian cuisine where he
incorporated Indian ingredients with western
techniques. Tabla has, as you all probably
know, received numerous media accolades including
three stars from the New York Times. And,
in addition, Floyd was named as one of the
innovators in Bon Appetit's 2003 Annual Restaurant
Edition and has received three nominations
by the James Beard Foundation for Best Chef
in New York. Floyd released his first cookbook,
"Once Spice, Two Spice," which hopefully some
of you have gotten, in 2006. It includes his
favorite new Indian recipes from Tabla, including
one of my favorites, the crab cakes and demystifies
Indian food and flavors and teaches how to
expertly add the Indian spices to American
cuisine. I ask you all to join me in welcoming
Chef Cardoz. And as two quick reminders to
the extent that you can close your laptops,
it would be greatly appreciated, and if you
have any questions at the end of this session,
please use the mics because we are recording
for YouTube. Thanks so much. Welcome, Chef.
>> CARDOZ: Thank you. Well, good afternoon,
and thank you for being here. What she didn't
say was I initially thought that I was going
to go into the sciences and I was doing my
masters in biochemistry when I got--I had
this moment in the lab one day that this is
not something that I want to do. I enjoy food.
I enjoy cooking. And as a kid, I saw all this
cooking in the kitchen with my cook at home.
For those of you Indian families, you know
that men don't cook in India and you have
someone do it for you. And I started hanging
out in the kitchen, and, you know, my way
of eating extra was hanging out with the cook
in the kitchen so she would feed me, you know,
before my brothers and sisters, and then when
I went to the dinner table, I got some more.
But I enjoyed eating so much that I started
cooking from the age of nine. I used to make
omelets and stuff and I used to do these barbecues
in India, you know, with my friends, and I
realized that I absolutely love doing this
and I have not regretted one single day of
my cooking because I get up every morning
and I want to go to work. On the weekends
when I'm home--I don't work weekends, I work
Saturday, Sunday, I'm off--I'm up early in
the morning, I plan my menu for the day. I
know we're going to have three meals at home,
drives my wife absolutely crazy because I
start cooking at seven in the morning. I go
shopping with my kids. I buy whatever is available.
And it's about passion for me. It's about
doing what I love to do every single day.
And what I do at the restaurant, at Tabla,
is that I try to bring these flavors that
I grew up with in India. When I came here
22 years ago, Indian food in the United States
was very bad. There was a few restaurants
on 6th Street, a few restaurants on Lexington
Avenue, and they did an adaptation of Indian
food that was found only in Mogul cuisine
and it had cream and butter and--I didn't
grow up that way. So, when I was approached
to do this restaurant, to do Indian food,
I said, "You know what? I'm going to do Indian
food, but I'm going to do my take on Indian
food because most people in the United States
don't know the kind of food that I grew up
with." And if you're an Indian, you know that
the food you eat at home is nothing like what
you find in the restaurants. It's seasonal.
It's light. It's fresh. It's absolutely delicious.
So, we opened Tabla. I opened upstairs, I
did my take which was French--I was classically
trained in French foods--as French and Indian
mix; and the Bread Bar which was the lowest
street-level restaurant was a space we had
which--first I wanted to prove to the United
States that I could cook. So, I concentrated
on that restaurant and my partner would tell
me, "Let's do this," you know, "Let's do this,"
and I was just doing stuff that I didn't truly
really care about. And then, two years into
the restaurant, I spoke to Danny, my partner,
and I said, "Danny, listen. Let's change this.
I always say when I retire I wanted a home-style
Indian food." So, in the Bread Bar, we do
home-style Indian food, which is not really
Indian food that all Indians in India eat,
but it's also a food that Indians in the United
States and England and Australia, what we
cook with the local ingredients. So, what
we're going to do today is we're going to
do a little bit, something of an adaptation,
okay. The lamb that I'm doing today, and I
think you're going to have it at lunch, is
a spice-frosted lamb. In India, when you do
lamb it's always killed, you know, it's not
cooked medium rare. Being that in India, the
meat we use is not aged and it's killed and
cooked right away. So, it's stewed. So, I
have adapted the spices from the lamb that
I--you know, in India, you always cook lamb
with black pepper, with green cardamom, with
mustard, with black cardamom. And what I've
done is I've taken a nice cut of lamb like
a lamb chop or a lamb loin or leg of lamb,
I treated it with spice and we're going to
make a little marinade today for the lamb.
And we've taken lamb loin and we're using
mustard seeds, black pepper, might as we go
for a black cardamom, but they didn't have
any, so we have green cardamom. And, you know
what I think is if you use spices, it adds
flavor to the dish and it makes it exciting.
It just doesn't, you know, keep it one-dimensional.
Yeah, lamb is great. You have a nice lamb
chopped, put it around the grill and roast
it. You know, there's nothing wrong with it,
but if you can add some flavor to it and make
it more exciting, why not? So, we--there's,
you know, and anybody comes into my restaurant
and says, "Oh, I don't like spices." First
thing out of my mind is SOL (ph) because everything
across the board has got spices in it. You
know, we can do a piece of fish or piece of
meat, but our sauces are premium, our vegetables
are cut as, so... But in India, you know,
we have, I think, over a billion people, and
the reason why our population is so big is
because of the spices, you know. It's good
for you; it keeps you in good health. And
now that we are eating more like the western
world in India, we're having more of the disease
and all the other, you know, rich man's diseases
coming to India. So, we're going to make a
spice rub. And, you know, what I do at home
is I never buy ground spices, we buy whole
spices. I have two little coffee grinders
at home, and in my kitchen at the restaurant,
everybody has traveler's spice grinder because
we make our spice mixes, you know, fresh every
single day. So, we're going to grind that
and we're going to add a little bit of oil,
rosemary and salt, and we're going to crust
the lamb. And what I like to do is--I live
in the burbs, so it's easy for me to grill
stuff at home, so I have a grill in the backyard
and I like grilling it. But if you don't have
a grill, you can put it on a pan and cook
it on a pan or you can even put it in the
oven and under the broiler. When I was deciding
that I was going to do this lamb, I said,
"You know, let's do something else that will
go with it." Now, most people here love chickpeas,
and in this dish of chickpeas is actually
quite close to the original that I'm making,
okay. So, we're going to do chickpeas, or
we're going to do cracked wheat, again, all
really healthy, good ingredients. So, is that
done? So, we're also going to use rosemary
with the lamb. Now, in Indian food, rosemary
is not very often used, but I believe that
when I take Indian cuisine which is a great
cuisine and I take French cuisine or German
or Italian or Chinese or Japanese, for that
matter, I stay with the traditions. Now, you
always do leg of lamb with rosemary and that
kind of works really well, like I do duck
at the restaurant, I do the orange--I'd make
an orange curry. There is no orange curry
in India. But I use orange juice and I use
spices that work with orange. I don't know,
like, I use star anise, I use fennel seed,
I use ginger. So, we have the spice--is the
rosemary in there?
>> No.
>> CARDOZ: And I'm going to add rosemary to
it. And whenever you do herbs, it's always
great to, you know, mince the herbs up right
at the end and not in the morning or the day
before because it kind of loses all the aromatic
oils. And I'm going to add a little bit of
oil to that and salt. And salt is good for
you so, you know, if your doctor says, "Don't
use salt," they don't know anything about
flavor. Now, the black pepper in there adds
a little bit of heat to it. And what I love
about black pepper is that it has this constant
flavor unlike chili pepper that keeps on building.
So, when you add black pepper you can add
as little or as much as you want. And the
great thing about black pepper too is it's
a great digestive. Black peppers are used
a lot in the south of India, and also it's
good because it helps in digestion, too. So,
we have the lamb. I love using my hands when
I cook because...
And once you marinate the lamb and let it
sit, you should let it sit in the fridge overnight.
I think if you let spices sit on a piece of
meat, it tends to, you know, permeate the
meat. In India, if you have a lesser cut of
meat, say, you use a piece of leg and it's
not as tender as a tenderloin or, say, a rib
eye, you want to let it sit a little because
it helps tenderize the meat a little bit,
okay. In India we use other tenderizing agents
like lime juice and tamarind and green papaya,
but with the meat we get here in the United
States, you don't really need to do that.
So once this is marinating and we have something
that we marinated earlier, we're going to
start shearing it off. In the meantime, what
I'm going to do is I'm going to make a sauce
to go with the lamb. And I use shallots, garlic,
ginger; I use tomatoes and mint. Now again,
mint is very, very traditional with lamb.
And again, who am I to say, "I'm not going
to put mint in?" If it has worked for so many
hundreds of years, I'm just going to keep
it and I'm going to change it. I like to innovate
a little bit. So, with the sauce, you're going
to add a little bit of olive oil. And I'm
going to put shallots, garlic and ginger in
there. And basically I'm going to sweat it
out a little bit. And when you sweat stuff
out what you're trying to do is you're trying
to release the essential oils. Most flavoring
agents in food are from the essential oils.
And again, I mentioned earlier about with
the spices being freshly-ground. You want
freshly-ground because there are spices have
these essential oils in them. And if you buy
a mix from your local grocery store of, say,
cumin or coriander or black pepper, you don't
know when this has been ground, it could be
from 10 years ago. You could be just going
to your backyard, picking up some dirt and
throwing it in the pan because that's what
it taste like, you know. I'm a big snob as
far as spices go, because I do feel that if
you are going to use these great flavorings,
why not use them at their prime. You know,
why half-ass it because you don't really need
to do that. Okay, we are chefs, we like to-—like
you tech people, you like to have multiple
screens working at one time. With us, chefs,
is we have multiple tasks going on in the
kitchen. You know, that's multiple windows,
if you will, because if we try to do one thing
at a time and you have eight hours to get
your lunch shift ready, there's no way the
restaurant is going to open. So, if right
now I'm making the lamb sauce at the same
time, I'm going to start cooking the chickpeas
and the crack wheat. So, for the crack wheat,
we have--it's regular [INDISTINCT] wheat,
and I think this is really a healthy thing
to eat. We have clove, we have cinnamon, we
have turmeric, ginger and shallots, and onions
and shallots. And I like to use clove and
cinnamon. Actually, there's this story I have.
I used to work in the St. Regis about 10 years
ago, and there used to be a princess who used
to live in the hotel, and she claimed she
was a princess. So we called her "Princess."
And she asked me to make an Indian-style pilaf
for her one day. I worked for this French
restaurant and she said, "I love Indian food,
make me a pilaf." So, I got Basmati rice and
I made her a nice pilaf. In India, when you
make pilaf, you always use clove and use cinnamon,
because it has this aromatic flavor to it
which adds to the rice. So, I made her the
rice, I threw the cinnamon in, I threw the
clove in, and we sent it up to her room. In
India, you know, when you use cinnamon you
want to put it on a dish so people can see
that you are using good cinnamon. It's just
a way of showing off. So, she sends the rice
back down to the kitchen and she says, you
know, "What are you doing, making dessert?"
I'm like, "What are you talking about?" She
says, "You got cinnamon in there. Nobody put
cinnamon in rice." But in India, we do that,
you know, you add cinnamon because it makes
it very aromatic. Indian food and Indian flavors
is all about the aromaticness of food. So,
I'm going to add a little bit of the spice
into the shallots and ginger, and we're going
to add the tomatoes. So, yeah, Indian food
is not only about heat. Indian food is a balance
of sweet, sour, spicy, bitter, and about texture.
I know you eat a good Indian food, Indian
meal, they'll always be something sweet, something
hard, something crispy, something crunchy,
something in between, and that's what makes
Indian cuisine exciting. I mean, you could
go for a dosa and you'll have a nice crispy
pancake, you'll have a spicy, you know, some
are like a coconut chutney. And what I do
with my food is I try to bring this into everything
we do, because I get this all the time in
my restaurant. They say your food is very
exciting. It's exciting because I'm using
these tricks that we've been doing in India
for hundred of years using texture and flavor.
So, for the cracked wheat and this is very
easy to make, I have the canola oil and I
want to add the whole spices in the dish.
Now, I believe that if you use whole spices,
you should add them in the beginning in hot
oil because (a) there are oils in these spices
and the oil helps extract them. And you put
the clove and cinnamon. And if you have cumin,
whole cumin; whole cumin works really, really
well with this. So, when you put it in the
dish--if look at it, it starts kind of shimmering
and I don't know if you can see that, and
that's when you know that you're extracting
most of the flavors out of it. So I have onion
and ginger. I pretty much feel that if you're
starting off anything, if you want to do a
boiled vegetable at home, if you add a little
bit of onion and ginger and chili and cumin,
it makes it so much more exciting rather than
having steamed broccoli or sautéed zucchini
or sautéed asparagus. You know, asparagus
is great, but if you add a little bit of mustard
seeds, a little bit of cumin, a little bit
of coconut, a little bit of ginger or tamarind,
it again adds layers of flavor. This is what
you want to do, you want to build layers of
flavor. So, I'm going to cook that until transparent.
And then I want to add my cracked--oops!--my
cracked wheat in there. And we are going to
add a little bit of turmeric. And turmeric,
besides giving that lovely yellow color, has
a little bit of bitterness in there and has
great flavor. And you always want to add just
a tiny bit because there are a lot of things
you can do with food if you add too much.
If we add too much salt, you can add potatoes
to a dish and kind of extract out the excess
salt. If you add too much chili, you can add
a little bit of acid, yogurt, tomatoes and,
you know, make that a little tamable. If you
add too much turmeric, there's nothing you
can do. You know, you have to either double
or triple or quadruple the recipe or throw
it out. I'm going to toast this a little bit
and then add the stock to it. And that's good.
Now, the great thing about this is if you
are cooking at home and you are entertaining
and, you know, there's all these tricks of
what you can make, perform what you can do.
And this is one of the things that can make.
And if you have a low oven at home, just put
it in a bowl and just take it in the oven
in 180 degrees and let it stay for up to two
to three hours. Okay, it's the same thing
if you're making the chickpeas, you can do
the same thing and hold it. So, we're going
to let it calm down and go, you know, really
let it all cook. And then we are going to
finish with a little bit of stock and the
mint. So while this is cooking, I'm going
to start with the chickpeas. And the chickpeas
are again--it's an adaptation of Gujarati
cuisine which is on the west coast of India
and next to north of Bombay. And the cuisine
from Gujarat is very different from the rest
of India being that they use a little bit
of sweetness in their cuisine. And that sweetness
comes from the Persians who came, you know,
Parsees, they came to India few hundred years
ago--and when they came and they brought their
cuisine in with them. And they always have
a little bit of sweetness, a little of sourness
in their food, and that is kind of being brought
into everybody in India. So with the chickpeas,
it's basically coconut that you can toast
in the oven and I like sometimes put it in
a sauté pan on the fire so it gets a little,
you know, a little faster color. And then
it's a roasted chili pepper. And this is—-it's
typical from the west coast of India, but
if you are a Mexican food, you know, fan,
they roast Chili peppers in Mexico, too, and
it changes the flavor of the chili pepper.
And now what I'm doing is I'm using a fresh
chili pepper. So, when I take-–when I take
a fresh chili pepper, I just take it and hold
it over the fire and it did get a smoky flavor
that changes the entire texture of the dish.
So, what we have is we have coconut, we have
a fresh roasted chili pepper, we have ginger,
and we're going to puree that and we're also
going to add the spice of black pepper and
coriander to it. Now we're going to add stock
to that and we're going to let that, you know...
It's going to continue reducing. And this
is actually really good for this time of the
year because you get some amazing tomatoes
in the green market. If you go on to Union
Square Market, actually today, Wednesdays,
Fridays, Saturdays, they have these farmers
bringing the best tomatoes in the country,
I think, in my opinion, from New Jersey. The
soil is red, you know, the weather is perfect,
and they get these amazing tomatoes. And if
you make a sauce like this, just take these
tomatoes, slice them and put a little bit
of salt and black pepper, just freshly ground
black pepper. It's just amazing, to make simple
ingredients so good. So, we're going to grind
this with a little bit of water, and we have
some chickpeas that we cooked earlier. And
if you have canned chickpeas, you can do it
with canned chickpeas too. I do canned chickpeas
at home. Fresh soaked and boiled chickpeas
are much better, but sometimes you don't have
the time and it's a great substitute. So,
as I said earlier, when you make a spice mixer
sauce, you want to cook it out on oil. So
you're going to start this, we're going to
cook the spice out a little bit in the oil
and I'm going to add the chickpeas. I mean,
I just let this cook. And we're going to add
a little bit of tamarind to this. Now, tamarind
is an acid. Indian food, I spoke about a little
earlier, has these layers of flavor and one
of them being acid. And in Indian Cuisine,
depending of where you are from in the country,
you would use a different acid, like on the
west coast of India, we use tamarind. So you
go from Gujarat to Bombay to Kerala, you'd
use tamarind. You go to the north of India,
you'd use yogurt, or you'd use tomato, or
you use lime juice. Also in the west coast
of India, and sometimes in the north, just
use green mango. So use green mango or use
kokum if you're on the west coast again. So
it's these acids that we use to build these
layers of flavor and to give the food this
roundness that Indian cuisine is known for.
So, I'm going to cheat a little bit over here
and use a puree that we already have that
we made out of coconut, the chili pepper,
and the tamarind. And I'm going to cook that
in a little bit of oil with the spice.
And these recipes are in the book. I'm just
winging it right now, but it will taste good.
I hate following the recipes. I can't stand
following the recipes. And when I cook in
the restaurant, these guys... My sous-chefs
follow me around in the kitchen. Every day
I was changing the menu and I change my menu
pretty frequently. I don't write things down.
I just go in to--we have a spice room which
is about that, a little bigger than that table,
and I get inspired by the ingredient. I don't
get it--I don't have something in my mind.
So, you know, in the night I'll call up and
find out what they have and say, "Okay, we
have halibut today." So, I'd tell my sous-chef,
"Okay, you know, just bring some halibut tomorrow.
I don't know what I'm going to do with it."
And these guys normally come at about 12.
So, from 12 o'clock they're hounding me. "Chef,
what are we going to do with this? What are
we going to do with this?" And I honestly
don't know. And around 3 o'clock, it's when
I decide, "OK, I'm going to change the menu
today." I go into the kitchen, open the walk-in
cooler, or on Wednesdays, as it's normally
going to change. I go on to the market, I
pick up some vegetables, I go in and then
I start cooking. And when I start cooking,
I'll tell the cook, "OK, get me fish stock,
get me tamarind, get me lime juice, get me
this, this, this, and this." And they would
be lined on the table behind me, and I start
cooking. And half the time I would use everything
they bought me and sometimes I will change
my mind halfway to the cooking, because with
me it's all about what the inspiration is.
And I don't try to, you know, put stuff in
that doesn't belong because it is very easy
to do that and then you get food that doesn't
make sense. It's about adding ingredients
that make the ingredient taste good. And then
after I cook, these guys write down every
single thing they do. And I have a database
of over 10,000 recipes. And sometimes they'll
ask me, "Chef, remember last year we did the
snapper?" and I have no recollection of it
at all. And you know, when I have people over,
too, they ask me, you know, when they eat
in my home, you know, "May I have your recipe,"
and I don't know what the recipe is. So, now
when I started doing is, you know, when my
wife asked me when I cooked dinner, she writes
everything I'm doing, and then I tried to
recreate it again but I can't. So, we're going
to cook this out a little bit. In the meantime,
our cracked wheat is done,
and our sauce is looking good. You know, for
me, cooking is about having fun, it's about
enjoying the process of cooking and then enjoying
the process of eating, because I think if
you cook without eating is no fun, and if
you eat without cooking, it's no fun. So,
it's about enjoying the company you have and,
you know, doing things that make you happy.
I'm going to use that. So, once this is cooked,
we're going to add our chickpeas to this.
And if you have stock, you can add stock to
it or you can add water to it. I'm going to
add some water right now. What I do at home
is I use chicken stock. You let this cook.
We need some more water. It's easier. And
while this is going, I am going to start my
lamb. And as I said earlier you can either
go to the lamb or you can, you know, roast
it. And don't worry about the oil I'm using
with the lamb because if you have protein,
you can't put fat into protein, you can't
put fat into carbs, put in into the protein,
so. Everything that is on the outside is going
to just stay on the outside. Anybody have
any questions?
>> I'm curious about your selection for oil.
I mean, you have two of them there. Actually,
I was a little surprised even for such inspiration
and you got this in your [INDISTINCT].
>> CARDOZ: It's a very good question. I use
a bunch of oils. I like to use, I like to
use canola oil because I feel canola oil has
a perfect smoke point for – when you're
cooking spices. You don't want your oil to
be too hot, because if it's too hot, it's
going to burn the spice. And if you have grape
seed oil, a lot of chefs is using grape seed
oil these days. Grape seed oil has the highest
smoke point. So, you could be heating it up
much higher than you wanted to and you could
burn your spice, okay? I like to use olive
oil because I think olive oil has a nice fruitiness
which adds another layer of flavor to the
food. I do use geese (ph) sometimes, but if
I do use geese (ph), I'll make sure that people
know that's got geese (ph) in it because of
the animal fat. A lot of vegans don't like
it. I do use nut oils in the restaurants.
I think nut oils are great flavoring, but
I use them more as finishing. I love peanut
oil but again, because of the allergies, I
tend not to use as much. In my own cooking
at home, I use a lot of peanut oil. But I
think you could have a bunch of oils and you
could choose as many oils as you want, but
you got to be careful on how you use them.
So, I'm going to season this with salt. Whenever
you season with salt any meat, you want to
let it set for a few minutes, like, I'd say,
five or ten minutes because it helps with
the crust on the outside, it absorbs the salt
going to the meat. Okay?
And when you have a spiced crust from the
outside, you want to be careful that your
pan doesn't get too hot. You know, sometimes
when you do steaks, you want the oil to be
really hot so you can sear it. But if you
have the oil too hot for this, you are going
to burn the spice and make it bitter. You
know, our sauce is almost done, so I'm going
to finish it up with some mint. You know,
cooking with spices can be so much of fun
and make things so interesting that, you know,
most people don't realize that by adding something
really, really simple to a dish, it changes
the whole complexity of the dish. Another
thing that we--we chefs always do is we like
to--we like to taste as we cook because you
are building flavors in there. And the other
thing that you want to put is, you know, put
a little bit of jaggery or brown sugar, you
know, to balance out the acidity. Now, if
this was a bigger piece of meat, I would most
definitely put it in the oven. This is very
small; you can do it in stove top if you have
to. And there's another thing that we do in
the restaurant is, when we are cooking a piece
of meat or fish we add a little bit of butter
to the pan and then we baste it. And that
helps with the flavor as well as... So, as
this cooks, if, you know, the longer you let
this cook the more thick it's going to get,
the chickpeas. And you want it nice and thick
because it just, you know, the fattiness of
the chickpeas comes through with acid and
the sweetness and the heat. And other thing
we like to do, too, in the restaurant is we
like to add herbs to a pan when we are basting
a piece of meat or fish because it just gives
it a little fresh flavor. You know, you could
do the whole garlic, you can do sliced ginger,
you can do sliced shallots, you can do spice
if you want. But it just makes it—makes
it more interesting. Now, I'm going to kind
of rest this for a minute. And whenever you
do, if you're roasting meat, it's always a
good practice to let the meat roast or let
the meat rest before you slice it, especially
the medium rare or anything less than that.
Because if you-—you cook the meat and you
go and slice it right away, what happens is,
as with protein as it cooks it tenses up,
and all the juice from the inside comes to
the outside. And when you go and slice it,
you got blood in the plate. But if you rest
it and you slice it, you got a beautiful pink
in the middle and there's no juice on the
plate. And it's also very interesting because
if you cook with spices there are very, very,
very many people who are very afraid of using
spices in their food. And in my restaurant,
I get cooks who come in all the time and say,
"Chef, I don't know how to cook with spices."
I say, "As long as you know how to cook, I
can teach you." And if you've known the basics
of, you know, fresh spices, using oil, you
know, taking care, balance, you know, don't
use too much, you can cook very well with
spices. If you--you know, I have tasted restaurants
where the food has got way too much chili,
or way too of garam masala, way too much of
something or the other. That's what kills
the dish. But if you use it in limitation
and you follow the recipe and you follow the
cooking technique, your dish can come out
perfectly every single time, you know. There's
nothing that's-—I mean, you know, what I
did here is not what you guys do. This is
not a rocket science. You just follow the
recipe. You know, I'm not discovering anything.
I'm not doing new web pages or new search
engines or any of that kind of stuff. I'm
just putting food together. And it got to
start from here, because if you don't have
the passion, you know, you can—-like I can
tell when someone is cooking without passion
in my kitchen. If a cook is unhappy, I can
see the product coming out. If I can go to
someone's home and eat a meal, and I can tell
you if that meal was cooked with passion or
not, or that person have a good day or a bad
day because it translates into the balance
of the salt, the balance of the heat. It could
be the most simplest dish that they could
be making. It doesn't-—like when, you know,
my friends who like to invite me over to eat,
and they try to make fancy. And I told them,
"Don't make fancy. Make what's close to your
heart because that's going to be good every
single time." And if that passion translates
into what you do and you eat it, you get that
joy. And with food, that's all it's about.
It's not about my ego, it's about the community.
It's about making you happy, making you enjoy
these wonderful flavors and partake of this
meal.
So I'm going to cheat a little bit and slice
this lamb right now. You know, just going
to plate this, a little bit of lamb.
And we'll put it on the plate. [INDISTINCT]
right now. Any questions?
>> Thank you for coming. Can you tell us about
the stock you're using? And do you cheat with
stocks at home?
>> CARDOZ: Do I cheat with stocks?
>> Like instant Bouillon, anything.
>> CARDOZ: I have two freezers at home. One
has ice cream and normal home stuff, and the
other one which is in the garage has my stocks.
And I have chicken stock, I have shellfish
stock, I have lamb stock, I have pork stock,
I have beef stock, and I have a vegetarian
stock. What I do is I buy whole chickens at
home, and I save the scraps. The skin, the
necks, the wingtips, and I put them in these
small bags. It drives my wife totally insane
when I do that because she'll open the freezer
one day and all these bags will be everywhere
and you know, once a month I make stock. And
I make the stock and I freeze it. You know
these small cork containers? They're the best.
And I think if you do that--I used to at one
point buy stocks commercially but they don't
have the body. You need the gelatin in stocks.
I do use bouillon cubes but not for everything.
My mom makes a rice dish with bouillon cubes,
scallions and tomatoes, and it's absolutely
amazing. And I'm not embarrassed to say that
I make-—I made that rice on Sunday night.
It is—-it tastes pretty good. But making
your own stocks, it can be difficult, but
if you have space to store like scraps, you
know, bones and skin and especially of chicken
or you have shrimp heads, save them. It just
makes a total difference to the way food tastes;
it can be so much better. And in the restaurant,
of course, we make-—we have a big steam
kettle where we make chicken stock every single
day. But we don't cheat with, you know, if
we say it's vegetarian, it has a vegetable
stock in it. We don't put beef stock and anything
unless it's beef. Or if we say that there's
beef stock in there, we don't put fish stock
or shellfish stock or lamb stock or pork stock,
for that matter, in any dish that doesn't
contain pork. I just like to respect people's
beliefs.
>> I have another question. You said, you
know, using fresh spices is good. Do you ever
need to sauté those spices before you grind
them off? I know my mom does that, and that's
one of the reasons I'm-—it's seems like
more of a pain, so I'm wondering if you do
that, or you just put them in, like cumin
seeds and stuff?
>> CARDOZ: You can use-—you know, there
are certain spices that you can use whole,
okay? You can use cumin seed whole, you can
use black pepper roll but pull it out, you
can use mustard seed whole, black cumin, fennel
seed; those you can use whole. Do you need
to cook spices? I think you do. There are
certain spices that you can use without cooking,
very limited, nutmeg, cinnamon, clove, black
pepper, fennel seed can be used uncooked.
But you can extract the flavor of the spices.
You need heat for spices to extract the maximum
flavor. So you can either do what I did and
start in with oil. That's one way you can
do it. Or you can dry toast it...
>> Right, that's what...
>> CARDOZ: Okay. All the other thing is you
can grind them like I did and cook them in
oil. But if you grind them and cook them in
oil, then you only have a liquid with that.
And in my book I mentioned, you know, best
ways to do it, but if you're going to grind
it, you want to make sure that you have a
liquid to prevent the seed from actually burning.
Because if your oil is too hot, if you have
water in there, you know, at 2:12 it's going
to evaporate. So, you have--it's going to
bring the temperature down, okay. So, there
are recipes in Indian cuisine where they start
off especially some bars where they start
off with whole spices and they kind of toast
them in oil with onions and coconut and stuff,
and then they take that and they grind it.
Now, in India, you have someone with a stone
sitting over and grinding it. If I tell my
wife to do that, my bags will be outside of
the house, you know. But you could use a blender.
There is one blender make which is called-—which
one do we use at the restaurant?
>> Vita-Prep
>> CARDOZ: Yes, it's called Vita-Prep which
is a great, great brand. Every restaurant
kitchen uses it, and in that you can grind
spices with the oil. So, if you want that,
it costs, well, I think, 500 bucks. But it's
a great blender.
>> Where would you suggest getting fresh,
high-quality spices in the city?
>> CARDOZ: OK, if you want to buy spices,
what you want to do is, and I'm not going
to name any of the big stores because I don't
know if they advertise on the website or not,
but I don't want to get into trouble, but
what you want to do is you want to go to an
ethnic store. You want to go to a place that
has a fair amount of, say, if you go to an
Indian store, a fair amount Indians and Pakistanis
going into buy them. Lexington Avenue has
a fair amount of stores in New York. Every
major city in the country I know has an Indian
spice store. In California; in New Jersey,
there are plenty of them; in Queens, there
are plenty of them; in Manhattan, there are
tons of them. And, if you see--because if
you know that if you're going to these stores
there is turnover and that there are people
buying. And normally what happened in India
was that spices that spices grew one time
a year. There were harvested once and they
were harvested for the whole year until the
next year when they grew again. And you'd
use them for a year. What's happening now
is because of packaging and we keep it for
a long time and it loses the flavor. So, if
you go to a store that has high turnover,
that's the place to buy it from. You also
want to buy small quantities, you know. You
can go to Edison, New Jersey, and you can
buy 1 kilo or 2.5 pounds of coriander seed.
I don't know if they store any 2.5 pounds
of coriander seed in my home, and I cook a
lot of Indian food. So you can buy it in ounces;
you know, 1 ounce, 2 ounces. And they're pretty
good. You can even buy them online. There're
tons of places that sell spices online; whole,
in small bags, 1 ounce, 2 ounces. So, that's
what I would suggest. You know, I would not
go and buy everything because, you know, if
you buy-—I have seen people buy half a pound
of, like, fenugreek. Fenugreek half a pound
is a lot. You use half a pound of fenugreek
in anything and not going to eat it, it's
going to be so bitter. The other, you know,
the other spice that they also have in this
recipe, which I've forgot to use is azevetido.
It's a gum and it's used with beans. It's
nice to put there with the chickpeas, which
I didn't. But you buy these containers which
are that big. I have a container that big
at home which last me for a year. Because
you use, like, an eight of a teaspoon when
you use it. Now, I had a new sous-chef in
the restaurant who said, "I want to buy things
in bulk," and he bought six cases of azevetido,
which I had to throw it because we could not
use them. It was so much. So, you want to
be careful what you buy and how much you buy.
Like, you know, the other thing with—-if
you buy green cardamom and if you use-—if
you grind green cardamom and you get green
cardamom powder, okay, as soon as you grind
green cardamom, it has a half-life of 14 days.
So, in 14 days it's going to lose half its
flavor. So just think about it, as it stays,
even if it's ground, you're losing all these
wonderful oils that help you. Has everybody
got everything?
>> So, for people who are just starting to
cook Indian food, what three ingredients do
think they should add to their cupboard to
start?
>> CARDOZ: The first three ingredients to
buy are cumin, turmeric, and I'd say, coriander
seed. Because you have these three things
you can do whatever—-you could do steaks.
Everybody has black-—I'm assuming everybody
has pepper in the house, everybody has chili
flakes in the house, everybody has cinnamon
at home, you know, and bay leaf. So, if you
have black pepper and coriander, you can make
a curry out of it. If you have cumin and turmeric,
you can make a curry out of it. You can make,
by varying these whole spices, you can make,
like, ten different curries just playing with
the volume. But it's fun having fun with them.
It's not about being intimidated or, you know.
It's not rocket science, absolutely not. It's
easy and fun and, you know. When I was—-when
I went to school in Switzerland, I was dying
to eat Indian food but there was no Indian
food in Switzerland where I was. I was in
Bluche, in the valley mountains. And the only
spice they had was a curry spice that they
have which is absolutely nasty and disgusting.
You know, if you're cooking, don't even go
and buy it because (a) you don't know when
it was drowned, (b) you don't know what's
in there. And you know it's got some turmeric
and it's got some fenugreek because can smell
it, but we had to use that and then it's just,
you know. If you can make your own spice blend,
it's so easy, especially today. You know,
you get a little spice blender like that,
and you can go anywhere and buy them. So,
it's just not hard. It's pretty simple, you
know. I've made-—I've made curries with—using
Bloody Marry mix at 2 o'clock in the morning
when I was a bachelor. You know, come back
from a night out drinking and you want to
eat something and there's no food in the fridge
but there's Bloody Mary mix and there's spices,
and there's potatoes. So, you make a potato
curry and you eat it with rice, you know.
Or a chicken curry with Bloody Mary mix, but
it tastes damn good, you know. But it's being
creative and using these spice mixes that
you have and, you know, as long as you have
that, the neighbors are going to complain
that you're grinding spices at 2 o'clock in
the morning. But who cares, you know? You're
happy. Well, thank you.